a wedding with an ending so disastrous
it is difficult to fathom
a Bus full of partygoers crashed as it
was leaving a roundabout
it happened in the hunter Valley near
the town of Greta an area known for
Wineries and tourism all of us know the
joy of going to a wedding a chance to
celebrate dear friends and family
they are some of the happiest times that
you can have
for a joyous day like that in a
beautiful place to end with such
terrible loss of life and injury is so
cruel and so sad and so unfair
the guests were on their way home from
the wedding when the bus flipped
police say the driver will be charged it
was a confronting and very traumatic
scene wherever you've got that
large-scale incident with that many
people it's going to be difficult for
anyone so our thoughts are with police
and all First Responders who attended
in a small country Community
tragedy hits hard the hospitality is the
is the way of life around here so really
to have something happen this close to
home it's pretty sad
injured passengers airlifted to
hospitals around the state
most in a stable condition
for now it's not known what caused this
crash in the middle of the night in the
middle of a holiday long weekend
and with apparently no other vehicle
involved
Nicole Johnston Sky News in New South
Wales